the first group of Central American
migrants who reached the us-mexico
border is being processed by Customs and
Border Protection agents organizers of
the caravan say eight people started the
asylum process last night it's a major
milestone on a month-long journey
Mireya Villarreal is in Tijuana Mexico
with the challenges the migrants still
face Matteo good morning good morning
that group is now with officials with
the US Customs and Border Protection
here at the San Ysidro Port of Entry the
migrants that you see camping out behind
me are actually sleeping just feet away
from that same entrance they are hoping
they will be a part of the next wave of
applications
dozens of people in the Central American
caravan raised their fists and cheered
in celebration over news that some in
their group are now making their case
for asylum a majority of the group of
about 150 are still waiting to enter the
pedestrian crossing to the US Sara
Marquez and her children are among those
waiting they fled gang violence in
Honduras when they say mommy I can't
take it I don't blame them I just tell
them that we have to keep going and we
will come out on top
Customs and Border Patrol typically
process about 50 asylum cases per day at
this port of entry but agents say the
number of people they're able to process
depends on the complexity of their case
medical needs
translation requirements and available
detention space caravans from Central
America have made this trek since 2008
but have mostly been ignored this group
is the largest so far and the Trump
administration has focused attention on
their journey during a visit to the
California border on Monday vice
president mike pence said the group is
proof that immigration reform is needed
but acknowledged the US will hear their
cases make no mistake about it
these families often women small
children are victims they're victims of
open border advocates who support and
encourage them to take a long and
dangerous trip will process them under
the laws of this country the Department
of Justice has filed criminal charges
for illegal entry against eleven
immigrants that were found in the United
States within five miles of the u.s.
border crossing for those that are still
here behind me sleeping for now and
waiting this city has become sort of a
community this tent city community and
basically they tell me they are here
they are waiting and they are in it for
the long haul Nora all right Maria very
al into wanna thank you